talk for a minute about casting you had
a real challenge finding someone to play
the role of Popeye Doyle
well yeah gene Hackman was not our first
choice at all in fact he wasn't even on
the list the first guy I wanted for the
role of Popeye was Jackie Gleason and
you guys remember Jackie Gleason sure
yeah to the moon but the Jackie Gleason
that was in the hustler
that's he was Eddie Egan and he was what
you'd call a a black Irishman you know a
drinker heavyset guy dark personality
poetic in a way and dick zanuck who was
head of Fox said to me no way
we're gonna use Gleason that's out of
the question because Gleason had made a
film for them called Gigot which was a
silent movie about a clown and it was
the biggest disaster in the history of
20th Century Fox I think it did zero
business for them and they wouldn't go
with Gleason and I had spoken to Gleason
and he was willing to do it the next guy
we went to was Peter Boyle who was in
the in a film called Joe where he played
bigot with a baseball bat who used to go
into minority bars and beat guys over
the head and he was a real thug and we
went to Peter Boyle and he said we
didn't have much of a script to show him
but we told him the story and he said
you know I don't want to do films like
that anymore he said I would like to I I
would like to spend the rest of my
career doing romantic comedies
and I you know hence Young Frankenstein
well he looked in the mirror and saw
Cary Grant and Mel Brooks our Young
Frankenstein but we have my lovely wife
Sherry who's here tonight we have a very
good friend named Phil Rosenthal who
created the television show Everybody
Loves Raymond and Peter Boyle was on
that show for I think nine years and
Phil Rosenthal told us that there wasn't
a day on the set that he didn't say you
know I passed on the French Connection
so the next guy I went to I said dick
zanuck said look you don't need a star
you don't want a movie star in this part
you want a guy who is Popeye and I
actually auditioned that he Egan but he
and I had a different vision of the
character he saw himself as you can see
as a kind of a pompadour you know he saw
Cary Grant too and he looked in there
but there was a guy who was a newspaper
reporter in New York who was a very good
friend of mine in my drinking days and
his name is Jimmy Breslin do you know
Jimmy Breslin yeah thank you
Jimmy Breslin is a great journalist of
the New Journalism from the 1960s and he
also knew all these characters and he
knew the street and I said to dick
zanuck would you go with Jimmy Breslin
to play this part and he said I know
Jimmy Breslin is why don't you audition
him so I went to Jimmy and he said
you're crazy I can't act and anyway I as
a favor to me we went out on a Monday I
had a cast Scheider
and the young african-american man in
the first scene Allen weeks
and I took Allen weeks and Scheider out
with Breslin and we improvised the first
scene pick your feet in Poughkeepsie and
Breslin was great he was fantastic and
then Tuesday he forgot what he did on
Monday and then Wednesday he didn't show
up and Thursday he showed up drunk and I
knew I had to fire him so when he came
in on Friday very contrite I was
prepared to fire him and he said to me
he said isn't there isn't there a car
chase in this movie I said yeah he said
well I gotta tell you I promised my
mother on her deathbed then I would
never drive a car so I don't know how to
drive I said you're fired and Gene
Hackman was the last man standing
he was proposed by a very good agent in
that period named sue mangers and she
represented Jean and she suggested we
use him and I never thought that Jean
was right for the role until later you
know and by later it was around the time
he won the Academy Award about then I
knew that he was perfect yeah